what's up everybody welcome to mega bet
it's monday at gamespot it's 11am on the
west coast maxell McGee ready to place
some risen and evil wake up max right
you're right yeah we're gonna play
Resident Evil on gamecube is a remake
that Capcom did part of their exclusive
deal with Nintendo back in the day to
support the gamecube didn't last very
long resident evil eventually came back
to the ps2 threads and evil for very
true um resume before was just too dang
pocket too dang good but we're gonna
jump into the game all right yeah look
how spooky that text is and that inner
cap t on valentine it's because then we
have all these lights on in here I know
really good force I want to move west
Raccoon City we are searching for the
helicopter of our compatriots bravoteens
disappeared during the middle of their
mission bravoteens Bravo teams
helicopter was a derelict dad his loving
the decision please Jill by the way good
safer from one side done something right
in the ship did you uh do you rem the
original opening the original game it
was all well first it was all live
action it was all of xpg nonsense they
had like intros for every character we
would be like turned the name like
Wesker the actor would like turn around
or this gun I'm Wesker it's like some
facilities action show or something are
we gonna see some western that's been
true some old-school ways good i love
this first got there gopro cams I don't
know Mom ago I thought Jill's like eyes
have no pigment whatsoever dude few just
a tree oh come on Joseph my Joseph
happened the suspense oh no all right
wesker West be fighting I prefer like
pre trench coat western so on the murder
can but votans like pre matrix Wesker
you Nina before he had magic zombie
kungfu powers yeah oh boy I messed up
feels like no I'm not feeling about this
I'm not really sure what's happening
which I'm a scared look on me Oh dog I
can't shoot a puppy okay wait I she's
gonna go with scared okay up grass
quick a mansion
that one dog is the leader of the pack
no thanks Wesker it's an old typewriter
what's an old type I don't have a memory
card so no so LOL oh no no memory i just
picked up an ink ribbon so let's all
make sure that i die that he doesn't die
because otherwise we're gonna be a lot
of trouble cuz i think you'd better take
a look at this is it I think it's
strawberry jam well somebody's put
ketchup on the floor is it ketchup I
with the lawyers do this what if it's
cats find any other maybe some mustard
got yourself a sandwich company man just
the the shadows and the lighting in this
game just so [ __ ] good excuse the
language pardon my french but GD it so
good chris is that you Chris Chris I'm
talking to you awesome that other dude
Barry found some clues you need some
lotion bro and r isn't you know where
the crap IM yoona doing get away from
him I remember playing this game the
original version with a friend did it is
how something like oh man when i get a
playstation i'm gonna give me some
resident evil but I was like nine and
then when I finally got the game and
tried playing on my own I was like nope
can't do this nope can't handle need a
buddy my name is beer hedo Barry oh
Barry wait a man up I like that I know
he's shot twice it was like I gotta aim
real carefully if its last one it was
been cool if you pulled like a like a
pic an ocelot thing yep metal gear you
want to like Torres gonna chill look I
need you to this is what you want me to
do right come on Jill come on come on
come on Jill you can do it she really
doesn't want to get off your top of it
well how do I push this why won't it let
me push it no dammit okay okay all right
but you got to get this little boy
remember be like Barry damn it be like
bury it all the love I name is Jill oh
you lost your knife no I got infinite
knives oh you stabbed him in the face
well he's kind of a jerk all right yeah
I guess its face this is face little did
Jill know that years later she would be
able to shoot zombies in the knee and
then do matrix come through moves to
somersault kick ya like I don't believe
he's dead Robin are yeah he's he's very
much alive make sure you aim for the
house make sure I run out of bullets as
soon as possible all right Barry
something happened where are you Barry I
know we ready to meet back in the lobby
Barry said here we go oh look at you
wish you made it really hard this game
came out back in 96 and developers
didn't let you be able to get through
certain things just easy breezy there's
the map mmm I don't know if I want the
man look at that I know like look at
that delighting that's just look at that
my god just the slight off and go home
all right you up there's a zombie
there's a zombie I can seem in the
mirror you seem in the mirror oh holy
cow yeah there is the silhouette of a
zombie back there in the mirror how but
he was a really pay attention he's
looking at his owner for a diva oh yeah
it might be a zombie baby do you still
got it oh so beautiful oh come here
often oh it's a statue that I push
Oh touch your mustache you I wanted that
they're nice what slightly why did you
fire up another round takes her while
you go I can step on it and step on dead
check dead in this check Oh God come on
there you go good [ __ ] what the haha
oh yeah yeah laugh it up oh it's
hilarious Oh line it up I'm a big deal
you've got to be dead you're not saying
for man in this game okay okay Peter
discovered something amazing while you
guys are gone let's cut to let's go to
the game feat here and check out Jill's
sweet footaction she's got going on oh
look at those moves look at those sweet
move she's a ddr champ that jill
valentine she can get triple a perfect
on mac 300 all right don't even bring
wet 08 on it all right sorry I love it
these are fun stop the music by ruining
the movement it's gonna get you hugs
incoming
and oh party time you to be whoa the
game will not let you enjoy your
victories got real spry there all the
time
zombies can now he's gonna he's gonna
corner you and dude there you go there
you go there you go duck and weave oh no
pubes oh he's gotta puke on you this is
really why we chose this game is just to
get to the sandwich to have this part
happen let's be honest what's that
rumbling I shouldn't be in that sandwich
right
quick act like you're gonna try to save
you something do something pretend to
save yourself do some a job out over
here what are you gonna do what does
this one do pull on the candles no no
secret thing maybe if I shoot the wall
but maybe if I should shoot it no no
Peter you gotta do something I'm doing
all day yourself save yourself oh the
door won't open
oh it's back up there Jill yeah let me
do and also fell down yeah this is why
Barry didn't take the lockpick by the
way to grab my hand
how about you just grab her hand God
give me your order still has to do all
the work she's so stressed out oh you're
down below this is immersive gameplay
design 101 right here it's so good stop
fighting for your life just give in
there you go oh I did not take long you
are dead and that concludes this week's
episode of megabit thanks for joining us
guys will be back next week I think
we're gonna play Jurassic Park on the
Sega Genesis like it was fantastic yeah
we're gonna bring a few of us in here
because a lot of us have really fond
memories of that game a lot of people
been asking for in the chat so we're
gonna ask what you guys wanted for I
don't know I'm saying here bring it to
you I check back with gamespot tomorrow
we're going to have the lobby yep Bobby
2 p.m. pacific time yeah right here
surging stuff there along with what oh
yeah multiple players comes on today at
2pm as well yeah man today so stay tuned
yeah so thanks for watching everyone
take care see you on megabit next Monday
adios